assemblée partisane et annonce
électorale stephen harper a déjà
participé à une douzaine d'activités
mais n'insiste pas qui veut à ces
événements tout commence avec un
courriel aux partisans conservateurs une
invitation à s'inscrire pour pouvoir
assister à un événement de stephen
harper l'endroit n'est pas communiqué il
ne sera confirmé qu'après l'inscription
en ligne
une fois approuvé les militaires
reçoivent leur billet avec code
numérique
raji cherian et bénévoles pour le
candidat de marque thomson
il en a obtenu quatre enfants une fois à
l'intérieur nouveaux contrôles il faut
présenter une pièce d'identité avec
photo et faire scanner son billet s'il
s'agit d'une assemblée partisane comme
celle des jackson la semaine dernière
les militants doivent en plus porter un
bracelet aux couleurs des conservateurs
pour prouver qu'ils ont été ennemis puis
la présence policière est imposante
même en pleine assemblée les policiers
sont toujours à quelques mètres de
stephen harper ce dispositif de sécurité
c'est pour notre protection dit à irin
awad une conservatrice de longue date
et puis si vous n'avez pas d'invitation
à ces événements pourquoi voudriez vous
y assister les organisateurs
conservateurs ne nie pas d'ailleurs crié
leurs invités sur le volet les personnes
sont admises aux événements de stephen
harper selon la nature de ses activités
soutien korité nike et nous n'avons pas
à nous en excuser mais les conservateurs
assurent aussi que les simples citoyens
canadiens auront accès à stephen harper
ici que le club leur radio canada
toronto